reprise en Mahorais c'est le nom de
l'opération en cours dans le son unième
département français en tout 18000
policiers et gendarmes sont déployés sur
l'île alors que le démantèlement de
plusieurs bidons villes pourraient
débuter demain dans celui de Kongu
chaque porte tantôt les recouverte d'un
numéro d'identification attribué par les
services sociaux au cours de l'opération
le gouvernement français pourrait
renvoyer de l'île jusqu'à 10 000
personnes en situation irrégulière les
Comores ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu'elle n'accueillerait pas d'expulser
on est dans une situation on est au bord
de l'insurrection et là avec cette
communication complètement hallucinante
ça galvanisé ses bandes ça a galvanisé
les autorités comoriennes et en fait
maintenant c'est encore plus dur pour
les forces de l'ordre au gouvernement
clairement affiché sa position il
n'acceptera pas d'expulsion et c'est pas
le cas hier par exemple un bateau est
parti de Mayotte et c'est arrivé aux
commandes donc entre le discours
politique et la réalité du terrain nous
avons un intérêt bien compris avec le
gouvernement des Comores parce que
eux-mêmes les Comores subissent une
immigration qui viennent de Madagascar
et l'Afrique des grands lacs et oui moi
je demande depuis que j'étais à la tête
du collectif des citoyens et maintenant
que je suis élu qu'il y ait un bâtiment
de la Marine nationale pour protéger
notre frontière celles et ceux qui me
disaient stèle tu veux ton mur à la
Trump et je sais pas quoi moi j'ai une
frontière qui est ouverte aux quatre
vents
donc on peut pas me dire sans avoir
essayé
avec les lecteur du Parisien le chef de
l'État prévient Marine Le Pen arrivera à
l'Elysée si on ne s'est pas répondre au
défi du pays retour d'expérience pour le
président de la République la réforme
des retraites il l'assume sur le fond un
peu moins sur la forme il reconnaît des
erreurs j'aurais dû plus me mouiller
peut-être que l'erreur a été de ne pas
être assez présent pour donner une
constance et porter cette réforme
moi-même
interpréter sa parole vis-à-vis des
membres du gouvernement je crois que le
président indique sur l'information
importante il était important qu'il soit
là et s'exprimer néanmoins plusieurs
fois pendant cette réforme des retraites
que maintenant si je puis dire la leçon
pour la suite c'est qu'il faut que
lui-même et que nous tous on soit au
combat vous trouvez vous qui n'a pas été
assez présent je pense que le Président
de la République au lendemain des
élections d'élections présidentielles et
puis sans doute pendant cette période
particulière de la réforme des retraites
qui ne extrêmement difficile personne
n'en disconvient aurait pu davantage
parler il le dit lui-même c'est une très
bonne chose que désormais il le fasse on
a l'impression qu'il y avait le
maquereau lui-même est à bout de toutes
les solutions de tous les mensonges de
tous les déni de réalité qu'il a pu
raconter au pays et qu'aujourd'hui à
part allongé les phrases utiliser
beaucoup de place il ne la plus grande
chose à dire au pays le président évoque
les futurs chantiers du gouvernement un
texte unique sur l'immigration ramener
vers le travail les bénéficiaires du RSA
et lancer un grand projet de
restauration écologique dans les écoles
finalement
pour
vous peut-être qu'ils nous regardent on
parle comme une éternité et on un nom de
mandat il s'est passé déjà beaucoup trop
de choses à un tel point que je pense
que le compte à rebours est déjà lancé
et que l'air Macron est en train déjà de
se terminer Quentin lecteur du Parisien
lui demande s'il a été blessé par
l'emploi du mot lol utilisé par la
nouvelle secrétaire général Sophie Binet
pour répondre à son invitation à
l'Élysée
je pense que ce n'est pas un formidable
exemple quand vous avez un responsable
syndical ou politique qui a ce type de
réponse écoutez le président de la
République n'a peut-être pas l'habitude
du franc parler peut-être qu'il faut
qu'il sorte d'avantage pour être habitué
à ce type de formule le problème en fait
cette formule c'est pas tant un trait
d'humour que un résumé de la situation
c'est à dire qu'on est confronté à une
hypocrisie totale cet après-midi le
ministre de l'Éducation Papen Diagne a
dû annuler sa visite à Lyon pour des
raisons de sécurité comme d'autres
ministres la semaine dernière il était
attendu par une centaine de manifestants
venus avec leur casserole 30 minutes
d'aurore boréale accéléré dans une vidéo
de 10 secondes un photographe feuille
mortaliser le phénomène extraordinaire
visible la nuit dernière à Douai dans
les hauts de France notre chiffre du
jour 26,50 €, ce sera désormais le
montant de votre consultation quand vous
vous rendrez chez votre médecin
généraliste sur les réseaux sociaux sont
partagés des clichés pris de la Bretagne
à l'Alsace mais également dans le sud
comme ici à Toulouse ce qui est beaucoup
plus rare